台灣股市一下子要來到48000點了
對不起 打嗝
我太High了啦
台灣股市 台指期今天漲了快1000點
台股漲了820點
我的1億0050賺了1600萬
我告訴你啦 賺這個還好吧
如果我買個正2或買個主動型ETF
是不是早就賺30%了
台股開低走高收最高
9月就戰歷史新高嗎
可是我1億的0050賺超過1600萬
9月要出清嗎
因為有可能48000
有可能50000
輝達砸千億買聯發科
輝達第一次投資台灣
除了買土地以外 投資台灣的公司
聯發科可以追嗎
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
全台灣唯一百萬以上
也是唯一140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
郭哲榮分析師
你不認識郭哲榮 你不認識哲哲
你一定是股市菜鳥
你回去問你媽媽認不認識哲哲
你媽媽說不定還認識
大部分媽媽還認識我
大家好
真的是別人笑我太瘋癲
我笑他人看不穿
我跟你講 連不是我的股票我都多準
你自己看啦
欣興開低走高啦 來
等一下 壞掉了
不給我面子 來
3037欣興開低走高
真的誇張啦
開盤基本上就相對最低點了啦
你找得到這樣的分析師嗎
今天錄影不是我的日子
給我壞掉了 等我一下
真的太High了啦 來
等一下喔
我們先點一下
看今天人數多少好不好
等一下點點名
你看我今天穿紅色的戰袍
台股就是太強了
哲哲 你是天公的孩子
再給你一次1億0050
再給你一次1億你自己敢買嗎
敢買嗎 投資朋友
我只問你敢買嗎
真的啦 很多人不敢買
我看一下 等一下喔
我看那個密碼 今天鎖住了
希望沒有問題
好了 沒有問題了
剛才那個軟體有問題
其實我要告訴你好不好
我覺得軟體有問題
其實我聊天 先聊啦
等一下再跟大家講 就是說
我要講那麼多嗎 算了
我對台灣的零股有一些想法
等一下再講
這跟我收會員沒有關係
改天再跟你聊
先講大盤啦
3037欣興講個股
欣興開盤921啦
結果大家以為921地震
不應該舉這個例子 這樣不好
開盤921 收盤970
1張賺5萬塊
最高來到994元
如果你最低是911到994
最多可以賺8萬塊
你開盤買 尾盤賣
至少一張賺5萬塊
5萬塊 你看一下重播
你們不用尖叫聲 真的不需要
我還是要聽一下 有沒有尖叫聲
你們今天不錯 導播
我今天沒有打算叫你們
而且你們兩個叫都是很慘烈
好像要殺了雞一樣
我沒想到你們會叫
我嚇一跳 來
等一下今年年終獎金
給你們多一點好了
謝謝投資長
因為導播沒叫 對啊
來不及了 好啦
來看一下昨天怎麼講 看一下
1000多元的欣興我沒有很喜歡
但是我認為明天就會打開了
明天
打開有兩種做法
第一個 你明天當日沖
我沒有建議
我從頭到尾沒有建議你當沖
好不好 你不要問我要不要沖
我知道有些人是這樣子
你看 我說你可以當沖
但是我不建議 為什麼
因為我不要負責任
我幹嘛給你負責任
可是我說過以前我有沖過
可是我有沒有說開盤就是低點
開盤後低點不就開盤買嗎
是不是 你可以做長期啊
可以買長崎蛋糕 也可以買長期的
只是我不想買欣興
我想買低基期的股票
你自己看我是不是叫你買
多恐怖
今天欣興又一路拉了
國巨呢 國巨今天漲4%
來 畫面給我
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你重壓就重壓
命一條衝就對了 搞什麼
有人說曾經有機會股價來到多少錢
然後我沒有珍惜他
你一輩子也不會珍惜啦
我告訴你啦
林志玲來了 張凌赫來了
你都不會珍惜啦
郭哲榮來了也是一樣
你不會珍惜我的啦
你不會珍惜400元的國巨
你也不會珍惜500元的國巨
你也不會珍惜600元的國巨
你也不會珍惜700元的國巨
我喜歡買低的股票不行嗎
我喜歡買便宜的股票不行嗎
今天台積電怎麼說
用量5倍啦
半導體展啦
AI算力需求年增5倍
我都跟所有主管講
你一天問不到AI 10題
我都覺得你們可以不用做了
我真的跟主管這樣講 真的
投資朋友 我當個主委
我要想怎麼寫文章 怎麼樣子
我只要講個架構請他寫
然後你需要什麼口氣
3分鐘就可以搞定了
寫得比我好
而且我現在懶得打字
我都用嘴巴講話
所以他們常常看到我自言自語
對不起 我剛才語速有點太快了
我降低
我私底下講話更快一點
AI算力需求每年增5倍
釋出更樂觀的展望 為什麼
因為有在用AI的人就知道
AI不是人
比我都聰明啊
我是一個非常自負的人
我再講一件事
你們以後就知道我很恐怖
我一開始就跟你預告
現在很多人模仿我的預告
你們不用AI的人
你們各行各業不用AI的人
你們會被那個行業會用AI的人取代
醫生會被會用AI的醫生取代
我沒辦法取代醫生
我沒辦法開刀
可是你可以幫你至少更了解
這個醫生講的話是對的
這個醫生這樣碰我對不對
有些女生譬如說觸診的時候
醫生這樣對不對
都可以問到
我生這個病 我感冒
是應該要看什麼科呢
家醫科還是什麼科
你要把更多的症狀跟他講
你可以輔助你的醫療 幫助你的幸福
不要省那些小錢
現在就訂閱
不一定要訂閱我頻道
訂閱Gemini 訂閱ChatGPT
我跟你講 我郭哲榮
當分析師不是為了賺錢而已
我要讓你知道我跟別人不同
我喜歡當預言家
你告訴 我欣興
我這個有本事 我跟你講啦
我1張100萬
我可不可以買100張
我可不可以買100張嘛 各位
今天最多當沖的話 我可以賺多少
800萬耶
我沒有跟你胡扯啊
我幹嘛當分析師 但我不能買啊
我是真的有能力跟你講
我不當分析師 我也賺很多錢的人啊
你算啊 你自己算嘛
我昨天有沒有說 開盤就見低點
一堆老師說5根 6根跌停板
還三根呢
我鼻子山根挺不挺 山根
還好啦 沒有整形啦
3根跌停板 4根跌停板
只有我講今天打開來 為什麼
因為台灣股市要5萬點了啦
4萬點的時候每個人笑我
沒有一天就漲停板給你看
天公的孩子又怎麼樣
你就是得要找運氣好的分析師
環球晶昨天跌停又怎麼樣
還有人嗆我
我說我精材漲停我都懶得講耶
我賺多少 今年我績效多好
不要開玩笑好不好
為什麼績效多好 我跟你講啦
我要是績效很爛
我在Threads發文章
在哪邊發文章 一定一堆人嗆我
現在為什麼沒人嗆
很多同業磨刀霍霍向哲哲啊
因為真的今年績效很好啊
可是我還是要告訴你
投資有賺有賠
我不會告訴你我每天賺錢啦
可是我要告訴你事實
我今年的績效真的不錯
未來我不知道
你要找到保證賺的
你去找詐騙集團
或是那種老投顧
每天都可以漲停板 我佩服你
你準備賠大錢
人在做天在看
我多少預言
我們接下來還有一個東西 你看一下
我說真的啦
你們真的是 如果你們做客服人員
然後做補習班的
你們相信我
這大概只有
你們只有2年的時間可以逃命
趕快改變行業
我跟你講 還有駕駛行業
大客車還有的救
大客車還是要
你自己看這個
各種燈光代表不一樣的感覺
更炫 有沒有看到
都在用 有沒有看到
井然有序
開車
你知道嗎 人還會有虛
你知道我疲勞駕駛之後發現
你知道什麼叫疲勞駕駛
就是所謂的疲勞駕駛是你很累的時候
你會發現你寧願出車禍
你知道嗎 我以前在讀政大的時候
去陽明山 我第一次知道好痛苦喔
去了擎天崗以後
下來4 5點
我差點喔 寧願我出車禍
那就是所謂的疲勞駕駛
下一秒怕出車禍
我提醒我自己 我還捶我自己的腳
還拔自己的頭髮
我後來告訴我自己
再也不熬夜了
很恐怖 熬那一次夜我覺得太恐怖了
這就是所謂的疲勞駕駛
結果呢
這種事情會發生嗎 不會發生
在自駕裡面不會發生
我是真的為你們好
雖然我講話很激動
可是我不激動我沒有綜藝性
你們不會看
這就是人性沒辦法
我只是很了解人性而已
可是我是預言家
你告訴我誰敢在39000的時候買
現在又覺得台灣股市OK了
莫名其妙
我告訴你1200的國巨
跟500多元的國巨都是一樣
AI還會再缺
我告訴你環球晶還會再噴出去
你不要買高基期的
那我還是要再跟大家講
我知道很多人看
也很多中實戶 大戶看
我在此再跟大家講
明年好像
明年開始好像7月份還9月份
零股交易是從9點開始
好像是每幾秒就交易一次
快要跟現行的制度結合
但我還是要拜託主管機關
因為我認識太多散戶了
散戶的想法想到2000塊就覺得貴
那如果台灣股市10萬點
台積電4000塊 大家不想買
大家就想買個10元台積電 最好
他寧願你分割
所以你一定要把台灣股市
整股的交易 整張的交易
跟零股交易合在一起 什麼意思
台積電就是用一股來買
不是用一張來買
台積電用一股來買
把零股跟整張的交易合在一起
當你每一件事情
你覺得台積電只有5000塊的時候
你就不會覺得像500萬
一張500萬 你覺得是5000塊
你就算1萬塊你都買得起
你有1000萬你也不會覺得
我只有買那個2張
你懂不懂 我只買2張而已
你懂不懂
我是買那個
5000塊是500萬沒錯
我只有1000萬的時候
你不會覺得只買2張台積電對不對
你會覺得你是買2000股台積電
都是用股 好不好
我跟你講 我的使命就是
創造大家的開心
增加大家的收入
這個Idea我會再持續推廣下去
希望主管機關能聽到我卑微的言論
而改變大家的人生
因為有很多人會因為高價股
而不買正確的投資的好投資標的
散戶都這樣子
永遠問我有沒有10塊的飆股
我現在已經變成是一個
希望不只當預言家
希望改變大家的生活
用股票改變大家的生活
不認識我的第一件事
我也不跟他報股票
我只有跟會員報股票
我說你買0050就好了
你不要問我飆股 什麼時候買
我有沒有說Anywhere Anytime
有沒有說Anywhere Anytime
有沒有 有
導播你來不及了
我決定還是扣你薪水 太慢了
有沒有講 有
導播 算了 好累
真的啦 你自己看0050
今天賺1600萬 創新高
我買在這邊
那個助理 再給我一個
我連續3年都買在相對最低點
連續3年
有人說我股票操作很厲害
也有人說我股票操作還好
但是自己拿出來的錢一定要尊重它
一定要相信它 隨便你們
至少我真的掏出錢的時候
就是一個相對低點
台灣股市47000了
早知如此 何必當初呢
全部都是自駕車了
很多行業真的會失業 相信我
今年12月7日
好像是從9點開始什麼的
沒有 零股一起他不是
你假設就我所知
假設你有 比如說你有101萬
你要買台積電 你要先買5張
1萬塊再買零股 這很麻煩
你懂不懂
我再跟大家券商高層講一個Idea
如果你可以一個程式包下去
同時成交整張跟零股的話
你們這家券商會成功
會幹掉元大
我是認真的 或元大自己改
券商高層能聽得進去我的話
你就紅了 聽不進去我不管
實施難不難就看你要不要改軟體
你們聽得懂意思嗎
假設我要買101萬的台積電
我就5張 然後加零股
不管 自己成交
反正我就給你總金額
你相信我 散戶會喜歡這個制度的
券商也可以改
我這個話就送給
有在看我節目的券商高層
然後願意去執行他的人
你們懂我意思嗎
就是我就給你一個金額
你自己幫我算幾張
台灣都是要算幾張
台灣的制度很奇怪
都要自己算 要自己算
我給你一個金額
你自己幫我算幾張
對不對 我1000萬
台積電我要買 我只能買4張
不是每個人數學很好
你就是 我丟1000萬
我就寫我丟1000萬
我財產有多少
我願意丟1000萬
你自己幫我算幾張
一般軟體要這樣子
然後還有零股多少股
你懂我的意思嗎
我就一直講 講到誰做為止好不好
我讓某一個券商高層
聽我的話的人去發光
去發大財 升官 OK嗎
還好昨天有買環球晶
哲哲寶貝華邦電有沒有機會
你有沒有想過一件事
你看它擴產才擴幾十%而已
來啦 人家說現在要10倍
最新的八卦是10倍
10倍 10倍
什麼叫10倍
來 我們看一下 等一下
來 10倍
AI需求每年增5倍
到5年過後是50倍
後面是倍數 5乘以5 乘以5
不是這樣算
我不管 反正就是5倍
每年5倍
50倍 不知道他怎麼算的
反正重點是50倍
50倍有沒有看到 每年5倍
對 每年5倍
你現在是2026了
所以2026 接下來是每年5倍
OK嗎
2029年整體系統的算力
是2024年的50倍
需求每年增5倍
為什麼 因為國家也會投資AI
因為企業也會投資AI
你懂不懂
今天如果有一個AI系統
有個AI廠商來
利用ChatGPT告訴我
我有人工客服 我24小時
當然我還是會保留一些人工的
只是說有時候他們在忙的時候
或過年期間能支應我
晚上深夜的時候有回電
然後甚至AI系統可以聽得出來
現在AI系統可以聽得出來
你的喜怒哀樂了
這個會員會不會成交
我當然去跟他買這個AI系統
我也可以節省很多成本
這是事實
所以我也跟很多業務 展業同仁講
我們都一定要精進
我們就是一個時代
我們不能輸AI
首先你要會用AI
你會用AI你就不會被人家淘汰
我跟你講以後客服行業
真的會很危險 好不好
我們還算有專業的客服行業 你懂嗎
真的 好不好
像電信業者這些都很危險
銀行的也是一樣
所以5倍 這真的很誇張 好不好
然後你看 輝達砸千億結盟聯發科
為什麼 邊緣運算也有
客製化的有沒有看到
他連客製化也要做了
所以客製化來了
你知道為什麼我要開始在3035的智原
為什麼要拉起來
就是ASIC題材 就是客製化
我一定要這樣講你才聽得懂
你才會記得
客製化 所以我的Timing來了
你知道郭台銘為什麼成為台灣首富
因為他什麼
在一個Good timing
在一個好Timing的時候出生
所以叫郭Timing
冷笑話
智原的Timing來了
接下來會漲ASIC題材
TPU晶片是專門客製化
我這家公司要什麼AI
譬如說我現在已經做到客服的AI了
那客服的AI我自己要制定
專門For我國泰或富邦
我自己一個系統可不可以
夠啦 我投資
全台灣的光客服 銀行客服就500億
我投資個50億也不貴
我每家銀行投資50億
你看多大的市場
還有電信業者 你懂嗎
我自己可以建個小AI中心
為什麼不行
客製化或者是說我不要
我們銀行業者就找一個
中型的AI業者
你懂不懂
我就是幫你客製化
然後把客戶資料
你自己儲存在那邊
這很複雜 你聽不懂
可是這就是你越聽不懂 他越有商機
這就是我講的 奧特曼講的
其實所有程式都已經到位了
可是應用很慢
可是就是應用很慢
讓這個時間的落差
讓你們很多人可以賺錢
我跟你講這一段話
大概100個人只有1個人聽得懂
不在乎啊
你只要看懂我看得懂的未來
你只要看得懂知道我怎樣的內容
你只要看得懂我就好
你只要看得懂知道我看得懂未來
這樣就夠了
我是不是不只一次 導播
我說10萬點很快就到了
我講4 5年是保守 各位
所以我說台灣股市
很快很多一堆股票是千元
真的不要用零股制度
券商高層真的要注意聽我講話
我會一直講這件事情
不要零股制度
因為你一直零股制度
大家會覺得台灣股市很貴
他會去買一些低價股 那個沒意思
真正會讓你賺錢的
反而是一些高價股
你高價股5000元一張
不是5000元一張 5000元的股票
實際上你用零股的制度來去算的話
用一股的制度來算的話
一股就是5000元嘛
你不用買一張 你要買500萬
那個感覺不一樣
你記得我說的這些東西 好不好
6488環球晶又拉起來了
別人笑我太瘋癲 我笑他人看不出來
我昨天 我問你一件事啊
我昨天為什麼 我完全沒有 完全不怕
我說別人在吃麵你在喊燙
欣興跌停
其他投信在亂砍一些概念股 幹什麼
幹什麼 你看 投信昨天是不是大賣
他不能賣別的嘛 他們就是贖回嘛
昨天00981A賣一堆股票嘛
要賣什麼賣
我就相信你們
你們自己都不相信你自己
今天環球晶又拉起來了 幹什麼
為什麼 看一看
郭哲榮講的好像對了
開始要邊緣運算了
ASIC題材
我跟你講這幾年
看壞AI的那些分析師
啪啪啪
打幾百巴掌啊
從頭到尾他們就沒有像我一樣
你們告訴我 你們那些分析師
外資分析師看懂我郭哲榮的節目
哪一個每天用AI問問題
問了超過十題以上
我每天都有十到二十題
我什麼都可以問
上知天文下知歷史
我最喜歡問了
真的啊 好多種運用方式
你不會用那代表
說怎麼可能問那麼多問題
我們公司高層有人這樣跟我講
怎麼可能那麼多問問題
我說代表你根本沒在用
代表你還是沒有熟悉到它多好用
它只是一個AI
那你們說這個AI通用
這個價格沒有多少
講那種話的人
AI只是一個幻覺
AI只是一個大數據而已
他沒有真正自己想法
但是你們真的沒在用AI
他有時候有自己的想法
2023年全台灣只有我第一個講
AI股會漲一整年
後來我講至少漲三年
到現在第三年
我再講一次會再漲三年以上
十萬點真的很快就到了
相信我 好不好
哲哲是現代霍金 謝謝
可是霍金有去那個島耶
你知道哪個島
來 今天大漲6000多人
ASIC IP 對 力旺對不對
ASIC題材就是專門做那種
專門客製化晶片的
所以接下來會漲這些股票
台積電 可是問題是
聯發科有完全不一樣的東西
就是輝達首次投資台灣的股票
聯發科
當然有部分台積電不需要缺錢
他為什麼不投資那個記憶體
記憶體很缺 為什麼不投資記憶體
對啊 南亞科難道沒募資嗎
真假 夜盤噴1200點怎麼可能
我看一下
你們亂講話 89點
可能把剛才的點數算進去
如果把台股漲跌幅限制
改成熔斷機制
都可以 這沒有什麼不好
漲跌幅限制我覺得也滿好玩的
看到漲停你不覺得很爽嗎
我只跟你講那個零股
因為散戶就喜歡買10元的股票 好不好
愛潑斯坦島
還有翻譯
這個點下去還有英文的 來
AI什麼時候出現T800
就10萬點不是夢
哲哲珠寶店也在噴
我已經 我蓋牌的股票
珠寶店我突然忘記誰了
京元電是不是
之前00940概念股我被他害死
也不能怪他 OK
大肌肌的哲哲
肌肉有沒有 可以了啦
來 我真的想讓你們摸摸看
我的那個手臂
導播有摸過嘛
有 我摸過
滿硬的 很硬
真的有點像鐵 我沒跟你胡扯
就是摸鐵塊的感覺 就是這麼硬
男人要硬啊
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
知道嗎 這樣懂嗎
好啦 扯遠了
會不會這一段又截圖
來 真的啦 真的
我自己就覺得有點像那個
就是鐵塊
來 昨天喊進場真帥
我喊很多次進場了啦
別人還有的笑我 好不好 是不是
日月光呢 來
矽光子黃仁勳說很缺
很缺啊 可是他就是進展很慢
都缺 都缺
矽光子是本益比太高了好不好
席勒本益比超過40
不行啊 你其實
我已經快忘記席勒本益比了
其實重點是未來的本益比
你懂不懂 好不好
我就跟你講嘛
就是趕不上科技的進度嘛
怎樣皮膚跟你一樣白
我有打一些雷射啦
定期要保養一點點啦 好不好 來
傳統產業只能投資
0050跟台積電
你說你在傳統產業喔
台灣現在傳統產業真的很慘
真的很慘 所以你就更要投資
你的工資不好 你想賺更多錢
你就只能投資 好不好 來
看南亞科 中實戶不行嗎
我看一下
2408南亞科
不會 南亞科才跌一根
南亞科最大問題是漲太多嘛
是不是 為什麼聯發科今天拉起來了
就是他前陣子有跌嘛
重點是他募資這一塊啦
我先喝個水啦
我每天都好High
我們先來看一下我們那個
環球晶嘛 對不對
沒有錯吧
昨天我還跟你講要趕快買國巨
買環球晶 你們不理我
珍惜1000元以下的環球晶
我再講一次
台灣股市真的很少
昨天一堆人哀欣興
我都不懂
我去年70元的時候
對 我跟你講
我之前不是有人
什麼搞個自救會嗎
我還是想要氣 那個168
他們168還會打廣告
我都不知道幕後的金主是誰 是不是
是不是某同業
自己知道是不是
我跟你講 我還在查
我該告就告
我跟你講 我根本不怕
你知道嗎 告那個168
告168結果沒有任何財產
那168總編好像財產不到幾萬塊
好像根本就沒有
我現在要查一下
因為要告兩個嘛
一個是告他的總編
跟告他們那個公司嘛
沒有財產是不是可以查封
扯遠了 為什麼講到這個東西
對啦 那時候搞個什麼自救會
欣興70元啦 快氣死了
你看多少人因為聽他們的話
欣興賣在7 80元
害到人了啦
現在欣興1000多元 真的是
我告訴你
1000多我就不想買了
為什麼我要買起漲點的股票
環球晶1000元為什麼你要買
環球晶以前就1000元了好不好
拜託 它不一樣
它沒在漲啊 你們看一下
你們看一下環球晶
我就是 看週線
現在1000多對不對
你看以前多少
你看以前也8 900
在沒有AI之前也8 900
有沒有 2022年
這是2022年
在沒有AI之前他也8 900
有沒有看到
所以他現在才剛開始漲而已
3037欣興不一樣啊
沒有AI之前他頂多就200元 好不好
沒有AI之前頂多200元
有沒有看到
2022年頂多200元有沒有看到
低基期啊 各位
你看不懂沒關係
再看一下5483中美晶
你看他現在250對不對
他以前多少
他以前就200多塊啦
中美晶在2024年就200多塊
有沒有看到
中美晶 來 這邊放大
中美晶這邊才244有沒有看到
中美晶前年的時候244
現在183元
所以中美晶這種矽晶圓題材
他們是低基期的
現在能選到低基期
就像我買智原
反正他也沒什麼漲啊
網路上還秀出來我400多元的簡訊
怎麼辦
愛罵嘛 我也沒辦法啊
的確有買過400多元
我也買過200多元的
我記得我也買過100多元的啊
一路做到啊
都這樣子嘛 2018年
不好意思 我也買很高的國巨
但是我也買很低的國巨啊
大家每天用最高點
你們都是這樣子啊
沒關係啦 100把裡面拿一把
賠最慘的就秀出來
我也沒在乎啊
大不了我不當分析師
反正我不會去故意害人就好
我沒有差
人在做天在看
我也認為我是這樣的心態
我覺得觀眾會越支持我
人在做天在看
所以我就是寧願選低基期的股票
所以ASIC題材現在的重點
重點是TPU晶片
就是我專門幫你製造
專門的一個AI晶片你懂不懂
因為輝達晶片是通用晶片
什麼都可以用 你懂不懂
我通用這一塊我要用
我ASIC這一塊也要用
所以我跟聯發科合作
我首次投資台灣的公司
這輝姑娘耶 飛上天耶
這輝達又有Google題材
又有 不是
聯發科又有輝達題材
又有Google題材
多恐怖 還要噴
那個拉回我要做多
那這樣就有機會了
可是那個不是
你們不要到時候麥格理1萬塊
那個邏輯是不對的 好不好
他們說TPU晶片賣很多
現在不太一樣
那是有輝達 好不好
他們的結果對
外資是這樣子
你結果對 但是邏輯不對
那不代表對
我還是不認為他是對的 好不好
真的 你要相信我
其實我們分析師在看人家研究報告
是看他的邏輯對不對 好不好
人在做天在看
我跟你講 你什麼都不懂沒關係
你就閉著眼睛買台灣50
10年後你就會愛我一輩子
我跟你講 人在做天在看
全壓國巨 就是我講的低基期嘛
奇怪勒
為什麼 以前國巨這種東西
它上面會有很多壓力
可是現在散戶是很瘋的
所以很快可能就化解壓力了 好不好
來看哲哲大吼大叫
心情都很好啊
你告訴我 我只要問你一件事
你們真的 你們拜託留言
你們不要講誰
因為我不要攻擊分析師
昨天是不是很多分析師
跟你講欣興要好多根跌停
到底哪一個人跟你講
今天開盤就可以買了
你跟我講嘛 光是欣興
這不是我的股票
這曾經是我的愛股
我賺完錢以後 我就把它丟掉了
我不是渣男 我把它抱很久
我問你一件事
你們舉手
你們看到是不是很多人
都不敢講今天欣興開低走高
頂多跟你講欣興我不買了 怎麼樣
那個廢話嘛
你們舉手 是不是很多人
哲哲身高178
不然為什麼帳號是178
一起發啦 來
昨天看到有三根 來
我壓國巨差點違約交割了
我又沒叫你借錢
你沒有借錢怎麼會違約交割
好不好 這個跟大家講 來
我信你不一樣 一起發一起發
華新科還沒有飆
漲停的聯發科很莫名其妙都漲了
還要他說 什麼意思 我不太懂
我不懂你講的邏輯
聯發科 重點是聯發科
有機會5000元以上
甚至6000元 好不好
昨天說欣興很高機率 好不好
很多分析師說先不要買
對啊 昨天欣興
每個人都說不要買對不對
我是不是拿AMD的概念跟你講
這就是真正邏輯
有些人就是亂用AI
被檢調搜索跌多少%
我管你那麼多
我是說美超微
說錯了 美超微
有沒有 是不是也是
還把標籤紙撕下來
用吹風機吹上去
吹風機把它撕下來 把它吹掉
非法走私AI晶片洗產地
跟現在是不是有點像
就開始起漲點 笑死人
邏輯要對 這就是投資股市30年
當分析師20年的經驗
你不要看我很年輕
我已經大吼大叫20年了
我已經當分析師當20年了 好不好
哲哲不要激動 身體重要
我看我哪一天應該是會在台上中風
然後就不當分析師了
沒有關係 爽 開心
我會減少啦
昨天電視有知名分析師說
欣興至少三根
只有哲哲說明天打開
而且我還說開盤要買
為什麼 因為我每天用AI
因為就是缺貨
你業界人士每個人都問
他們只會問部分的
對 我聽說AI缺貨
我聽說ABF載板很缺
我聽說真的他們明年訂單很滿
我又聽到台積電說 很多人講
所以為什麼台灣股市
台灣股市NO.1
我忘記跟你講這個東西
你看韓國股市要死不活
台灣股市已經要噴出去了
你比較一下
不要流行什麼韓國歐巴
你看這個台灣帥哥比較厲害 知道嗎
我帥哥的
有準就帥啦
什麼歐巴 是不是
不要看什麼早春晴朗
我昨天看一看 我看了有點想睡覺
我明天再把早春晴朗的梗
跟我們的節目結合一下
因為這個熱度還沒炒起來
OK 哲哲什麼都看
你知道為什麼看那部影片嗎
我硬要把節目合在一起
看起來滿無聊的 看前兩集
我不知道 後面有人說比較好看
不過那個聽說他講的一些名言
他那個總裁滿機車的
我有時候講話也滿機車的
所以我不想看那一個
扯遠了
台灣股市為什麼那麼厲害
你看台灣股市NO.1
到底誰敢在這邊買
我告訴你9月我不會賣
其實我心裡想的是6萬點要賣
但是我不把話講死
至少5萬點
所以5萬多點賣掉
你不能怪我
我講實在話 我也沒欠各位
你跟著我買你都賺錢
只是我告訴你
基本上我要5萬點以上賣
甚至有可能6萬點賣
6萬點賣的機率最高
這樣知道嗎
因為6萬點我會賺5千萬
你知道為什麼嗎
因為我現在賣沒有用
因為我年底才剛交救護車
很多人說一下子要買22台
拜託 22台是1億多
慢慢來嘛
我希望我還能再活22年
基本上應該做得到
每年捐1台 捐個1億多台幣
我覺得回饋社會
買這些車比買法拉利 買大G
還開心 真的是
回饋社會 幫忙到大家
你們相信我
你們不理財 財不理你
你們最傻就是把錢放在銀行
尤其這接下來黃金的3年到5年
台灣股市真的會突破10萬點
我再希望真的證交所
相關的主管機關
傾聽我微小的言論
真的要把零股制度跟整股制度
1000股那個制度合在一起
這樣散戶才不會覺得台積電很貴
不然你每個都要分割
分割不完 懂嗎
而是我們交易制度要改變
不是要買一張
不是一買就要買個200萬
以後台積電變5000元怎麼辦
以後台積電變成一張1000萬怎麼辦
你只能買零股
為什麼要分兩種 合在一起
真的 我希望大家自己也去寫信
我為了台灣的交易量好
好不好 回饋社會真棒
所以明年可能就很快6萬點了
剛好明年賺5000萬再捐1台救護車
每年OK
聯電快追上世界了 有需要換股嗎
你知道前年我還因為聯電
被人家罵得要死 氣死了
好像棄兒一樣
不會啦 棄兒是說那個
被丟棄的兒子一樣
不會啦 低基期一樣
他根本沒漲 說什麼傻話你自己看
在這個區間等於變成是
我今年年初到現在都沒動
這是今年年初 這是二月
來亂的喔
不會 我都是選低基期的
我跟你講 我不選什麼南亞科
我不選欣興
我寧願少賺
南亞科我幾塊買的
大聲說 50幾塊 40幾塊
我就是喜歡買低基期的股票
台灣股市現在那麼貴了
雖然會漲到10萬點
我不能買便宜一點的股票嗎
漲10萬點你知道到時候
環球晶多少錢
2000塊 3000塊
不是不可能
你說我的台語行不行
台語還可以啦
我都跟兒子說以後要捐救護車 對啊
不要 叫你兒子先孝順你
好不好 百善孝為先
說哲哲說的好不好 OK
mei你好 OK
跟你兒子講
說投資長說的
買救護車比特斯拉鷹翼門開心嗎
特斯拉我到現在還沒開
我6月就拿到了
到現在還沒開 我很忙耶
特斯拉好像公差有問題
我左右邊的縫隙 洞不太一樣
它的縫隙好大
我很怕那個沙子吹進去 真的
真的我很忙 我真的超忙
來 聯發科怎麼看
聯發科現在看起來有機會6000元了
因為那個意義不同 你懂不懂
台灣最大的那個ECB的募資案
如果我沒記錯的話
第二個 輝達第一次首次投資
投資也不是投資一點點
你是投資9成
就這一次的募資案9成 你懂不懂
哲哲台灣50賣會說 一定會說
為什麼要不說 賺錢為什麼不說
而且也是當天說
你隔天還可以賣
不用捐救護車 因為哲哲會捐
對 把錢省下來
叫你兒子孝順你 說哲哲說的
哲哲會賺錢
我認為就是我孝順我爸媽
雖然小時候 我覺得我爸媽
也不要這樣講 變成批評
我覺得對我的管理還好啦
可是我都跟我自己講
有他們才有我 好不好
很多人願意跟哲哲合作
也是因為我說話算話
我覺得成功人士很多人
我不敢說我成功人士
可是很多成功人士都很孝順
你看黃仁勳也都是帶著爸爸是不是
叫你兒子要成功要孝順爸媽
好不好 OK嗎 哲哲的肺腑之言
好 那跟大家講 來
Threads上有一堆
沒有藍勾勾的假哲哲在帶風向
對啊 那很累
我每天大概封鎖個5 60個吧
導播你也幫我封鎖是不是 沒錯
你也幫我封鎖
我就封鎖60個了 我快累死了
我不想封鎖了
南亞科什麼時候可以進
你不要管南亞科
你也可以買群聯
記憶體也會很缺
你看AI的需求一年5倍
不是50%
不要擔心 群聯這邊昨天爆量
為什麼量有時候是假的
昨天是MSCI生效
你不要看好不好
前陣子一堆人說 哲哲量縮
量縮又怎麼樣
我管你量不量縮
你們沒有在用AI在講什麼廢話
是不是 只看技術分析就最大的問題
看技術分析國巨不能買
上面籌碼賣壓那麼大
可是如果你看的是AI
很多股票會漲1倍 2倍
台灣股市會上10萬點
突然4萬點的時候
你會選一個股票還沒漲的
國巨到現在他股票沒有漲多少
800元以上國巨我可能就走掉了
為什麼我不能輕輕鬆鬆賺個60%
而且賺這60%我還可以怎麼樣
救很多人
我告訴你 你們1200的
你們現在趕快給我
我沒有說一定要
可是你要解憂
你要解救你的1200國巨
你就只能攤平
但是首先你不要融資 你不要借錢
1200買一張 500多元買一張
是不是 那結束下來對不對
大概800多元就解套了
800元以上的賣壓就很大了
1000元以上賣壓更大
你不趁現在給你低接
或者你做價差
我告訴你 你賺不了錢的啦
你沒辦法解套
別人都還在數10萬點
你是  我的國巨總算解套
你不要那麼悲哀好不好
哪有個分析師漲停的時候跟你臭屁
跌停的時候照樣跟你講
叫你ALL IN就ALL IN
是不是 買進國巨 悲喜加劇
你看哪有這麼有話題的
1200不是我叫你買的
1000元也不是我叫你買的
800元以上也不是我叫你買的
我買500多元啊 買到400多元啊
我是來救你的
我是來救00981A 知道嗎
來 鴻海有沒有機會300
有啊 怎麼會沒機會
等而已啊 就是牛皮嘛 是不是
百善孝為先
請問一下精材會進處置嗎
現在處置不重要
2分鐘交易一次 你知道嗎
哲哲開直播的時間
預定2點半都是2點40
不好意思 我最大問題就是遲刻魔
我朋友公司的設計部門
今年資遣了一堆人
導播有看到喔
影片也會有危險
真的都不太需要
我們都盡量的不要用資遣的方式
有些人轉業務 轉分析師助理
哲哲賺到錢又捐救護車 不會太摳
如果我算摳
那應該很多公司的領導
很多公司的主管老闆算很摳啦 更摳啊
我不敢說我非常非常大方
但是絕對不算摳
我們的平均薪水應該
不論是分析師的薪水還是業務的薪水
都是別家投顧的2倍以上 摳嗎
哲哲 因為你們業績好
我可以多找一些業務人員啊
是不是 不是這個原因啊 好不好
真的是因為制度
我都願意大家賺多一點錢 好不好
那個不用說
不用說誰是我的弟子
不要這樣講 不要這樣講
每個分析師像助理他現在在訓練
等到他當分析師的時候
我也不會說我有訓練他
我覺得不需要
不需要活在我的陰影之下
所以沒有誰訓不訓練
我都希望每一個分析師
有覺得說哲哲幫到他就好了
我不需要 好不好
來 我們來看一下 現在幾分
哲哲都很愛粉絲 愛大家
把股票的操作點位跟大家講
沒有 我最愛會員
你們不要想太多
你會當沖嗎 我還會令狐沖
當沖當然會 但是我不建議
叔叔有練過 好不好
京元電還會漲嗎
對 剛才有講說珠寶店 我看一下
京元電今天也拉起來 還有日月光嘛
日月光是多少 3211是不是
順達
日月光也還好 日月光不會什麼跌
就是牛皮權值股
華新科可以進 我跟你講
我為什麼要講國巨
國巨會拉到800塊
很多股票會漲個80% 100%好不好
再講一次
國巨會拉到
國巨如果會反彈60%
很多股票會漲
很多被動元件 華新科 禾伸堂
從低到高 信昌電
會漲100%
我再講一次 我買國巨是怎麼樣
是節目效果
我的意思是說 我真的有買國巨
可是如果我想要
更好的績效 更猛的績效
我應該買被動元件其他的股票
可是因為我會員太多了
其他股票塞不了我的牙縫
其他股票我一買就容易漲停板
那賣也很麻煩 懂不懂我的意思
我是要告訴你華新科會漲更多
這樣懂嗎
好不好 Understand
華新科會漲更多
所以你想要又有名的
然後漲得又比國巨多的被動元件
你買華新科就對了
這樣知道嗎
比較穩的
比較不容易破底的就國巨
你要比較刺激一點點 又有點穩
因為華新科畢竟是老二
就買華新科
想要又有一點名氣
然後再刺激一點
那就既生瑜何生亮
既生巨禾伸堂
就是禾伸堂 這樣懂不懂
2018我是被動元件
開玩笑 第一代被動元件是我在做的
你知不知道
一炮而紅 你知不知道
有沒有搞錯啊
我說我是被動元件王子
沒有人敢跟我講說
他是被動元件皇太后
舉這個例子是不是很奇怪 算了啦
台勝科一直跌 我攤平
現在賺20% 不錯喔 是不是
來 華邦電也是一樣
都是華家軍嘛 是不是 焦師傅
我跟你講 華邦電我還想再買
我是認真講的
記憶體我就想買便宜一點
但是華邦電不算便宜
我只是說從高檔的算啦
記憶體還會缺啦
看一下0050
再給大家臭屁一點 有沒有看到
買這邊 買這邊 買這邊
是不是
今天這邊厲不厲害
你在這邊 厲不厲害
一切的一切預告在前面
我不去事後話 我也不去馬後炮好不好
哲哲為什麼每天梗那麼多
這是天生的
我的反應不好意思 比較快
而且我的梗喔 我不喜歡人家
人家有些網路笑話或怎麼樣
我沒有要講誰 很多人都這樣子
我就是想到什麼就亂講
你是被套牢的元件王子
來 來找我好不好
我幫你解套 好不好 OK嗎
哲哲你一直搞笑還這麼準
其他分析師怎麼辦
我有跟業界很多分析師講了啦
我們是把餅做大
你自己看分析師現在的收入
都跟以前差很多了
很多以前覺得分析師只會喊漲停板
都不看的
所以我們是把餅做大
某種方面哲哲有幫忙到大家
不要覺得哲哲很臭屁
然後講話很討厭
把我消滅了 餅也不會變更大
你看他那個張姓分析師攻擊我
身體有比較好嗎
業界都知道啦
現在身體不好啦
視網膜剝離啊
心肌差點梗塞啊
我要提告的時候
他自己跟法官講的
他開大刀啊
是不是 他還不見一陣子了
公司營收還下滑
他如果覺得公司一開始營收會下滑
他會攻擊郭哲榮嗎
根本不會
所以那些其他分析師
除非是傻了才會想再攻擊郭哲榮
而且我一定猛烈回擊
我根本不在乎錢
就少買一台救護車拿去找律師就好啦
看他要不要一起花
我花500萬 他花50萬
我也開心 我是認真的
你們這些同業都不了解我郭哲榮
當然你如果跟我好 我一定跟你好
為什麼哲哲會變那麼硬
因為我發現我太客氣不行
這個社會都這樣
會霸凌別人的人
都以為被霸凌的人
我才不相信什麼鐵拳教義
要找人來救你
沒有用啊 那都沒有用
真實社會是人家要霸凌你
你要把他反擊
就這麼簡單
可是你不要去主動攻擊人家
好啦 扯遠了
可是我告訴你 真的
你們如果有小孩
你一定要教他這個東西
沒有用 不要說
我們當然不要去惹人家
可是真的被霸凌
有沒有 就像小偷一樣
任何小偷都可以解開你家的鎖
那為什麼他不偷你
因為偷你家的比較麻煩
霸凌的人為什麼會霸凌你
因為霸凌你比較簡單
被霸凌比較麻煩對不對
他就找別人霸凌
會霸凌人的個性都是一樣 懂不懂
我跟你講的是社會厚黑學
可是是實在的
以暴制暴 不能這樣說
而是說人家要攻擊你要反擊 好不好
對 你要這樣 好不好
軟土深掘 不是這個意思
是說人太好
硬要講也是可以
軟土什麼 我不會講台語
外資買267億你看就拉那麼多
籌碼太便宜
我說量縮還能拉 不就拉起來嗎
我告訴你 上個月這個時候
你看我是7月30號買的
是7月30號對不對
7月29號 30號
到現在一個月多幾天而已
賺1600萬
如果是買 現在幾分了
跳那麼快
是那個00多少
00981A賺30%吧
是不是 賺30%吧
今天創一個新高吧
是不是 今天創新高了 沒錯
今天第一次創新高
00981A 是不是 好不好
好啦 我幫你看
聯茂可以進場嗎
不要一直講同業的事情 煩死了
祝福他們
141萬訂閱者
其實分析師很簡單
就是真的不行 覺得自己很厲害
參加選股比賽
我也是參加選股比賽紅的
你覺得你自己厲害也OK啊
來啦 最近10年
9到12月第四季表現有沒有看到
9月上漲機率30%
今年9月還能漲 有沒有看到
可是整個第四季上漲機率90%
而且平均點數
我換算台股現在點數
大概差不多怎麼樣
為什麼是這樣加
天啊 助理真的是 我頭好痛
5%啦 我叫他平均漲跌幅
助理你都沒盯
對不起 這兩位
尤其助理現在還在訓練當中
我的頭很痛 這個是錯的
是這個5%乘上現在的4萬多
換算台股多少
平均大概漲2000多點
他是把這個直接漲點算進去
我有跟他講說乘以現在的%數
好累喔 我教他教了20分鐘這個表格
我好難過也好生氣
5.87%乘上現在的4萬多點多少
2000多點嘛 對不對 沒錯吧
2000多點以上
有點生氣 可是我要結束了
請助理馬上重做這個字卡
所以台灣股市第四季
整個來說應該要漲2000多點以上
這樣知不知道
算一算 我說平均 過去10年
算一算2000多點不就5萬點
我早就算好了
現在快47000了
再加個2000多點不就5萬
今年不就5萬
平均要漲5%
最後幾分鐘了
51了 要結束了
每天講那些同業的事
都沒意義 沒營養
真的沒營養 來
可是不講 他們就是
老虎不發威當病貓 沒辦法
恭喜6488環球晶
開高走高一路急拉
大漲將近9%
買進到現在最高已經大賺81%
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
我之前賺了快170%我還沒走
我告訴你 我要賺大的我跟你講
我要賺大的
精材賺121%還沒走
我要賺大的 一堆股票拉起來
帆宣今天也拉起來
我沒時間了 我告訴你
一堆股票拉起來了
今天國巨最厲害
我告訴你國巨為什麼今天可以拉
昨天跌停板我叫你
我不是叫你買被動元件
你看一下國巨
我不是叫你買
今天漲了4% 是不是
環球晶我不是叫你買
欣興我不是說開盤低點
是不是 開盤是不是見低點
我一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE
@s178
告訴我說哲哲 會費怎麼算
告訴我說哲哲 我要賺大錢
我竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位 Byebye